thank you Yasser alireza first of all
welcome to the show welcome back to
Romania how do you feel up to this point
about this tournament about your
performance yeah
um obviously disappointed with how it's
going for now
um I think I guess Wesley was the
decisive guy of course and it was a very
complicated game and I missed G5 so and
after that was all down here so
um but yeah now against Anish the second
game I'm happy with the game I played
with black
and today was nothing special you even
perhaps got a slight advantage against
arnish so definitely it was moving along
the right way yeah yeah exactly but I
didn't want to over push again like I
did against Wesley so
um for now I just I'm happy with how I'm
playing but the result is not so big
would you say that in classical chess
especially since you haven't played in a
very very long time did you feel a bit
Rusty as we were entering this yeah for
sure like I didn't play for my last
event was thinking in September yes
I was out of classical game and
I think I have to come back slowly
slowly sir and it's um best opportunity
in Romania to do that and it's almost
reminiscent of last year you started off
slowly in Romania but after that you
picked up uh steam in the other events
as well and it did amazing you ended up
winning the grandchild Story You're the
defending Champion Now take us through
today's game against Richie who we know
is a very intriguing player but he
surprised you at all with the Petrov
yeah of course he's he plays everything
so it's like impossible to prepare
against him it's really amazing and I
expected French French okay yeah because
he's still and of course I expected his
Sicilian these four nights
puts with uh yeah no no 96 96 or he's
expert of this minor 696 yeah yeah 966
he's he was playing it in candidates
most of all the time so yeah yeah and
but okay he also plays Petra but I
didn't have time to check
also and he planned he played Petrov I
wanted to get something quiet and in
general Petrov is probably draw so oh
yeah
um and he surprised me with Knight C6
special 5 and I couldn't remember my
preparation because it's a lot
most
challenging line for white yeah yeah
um I couldn't remember my preparation
and I just played some random stuff and
it didn't work out really well and his
play was A3 I remember was some kayaking
game in Canada's 2018 I think but
nothing more I could remember that's
kind of for uh perhaps the first big
game in this particular line and he
tried this A3 yeah but I couldn't
remember the details what is the point
of A3 but
yeah I just this game was nothing
special yeah he played very good the H6
move is brilliant
um normalist and risky to play H6 but he
knew the plans so
picking of opening preparation and being
so difficult to get anything with the
white pieces especially
um how do you generally prepare for this
type of tournaments classical events
specifically yeah it's not easy for
um you should be a bit lucky always to
pick up a win in this kind of tournament
for instance Wesley against me was lucky
and also many other guys here that mean
you have to you kind of win by opening
so
um
you have to use your chances and
processing is basically a good Advantage
out of opening which is the most painful
thing because you cannot ever get
advantages against obviously but
um yeah it's difficult but you have to
work hard right and that's one of the
things right Wesley feels like a counter
puncher right he waits Waits Waits and
if you over push then he Strikes Back
how would you characterize your style
are you a counterparter are you taking
more risks in general you just take more
risks and that's why you lose more
points than this but you also win yes I
like a lot yes for sure but
um basically it's always like at the top
in crunchy stores so for instance last
year also he was competing against him
so
his stone is more stable than me but he
gets less wins also than me so don't
make it's a different type of
styles
alireza at the big topic of discussion
has been your fashion Scythe career now
I see you're making some fashion
statements with these clips on I really
like them how is that going
um yeah it's I think in general I wanted
to always have something outside of
Chess because it's
just to play your whole life chess is
not it's a bit weird for me so
um but I always loved playing chess but
the fact that I'm living in Paris now
and everything is in that direction in
Paris there is a good opportunity there
but in general I'm still in chess of
course are you enjoying that uh yeah
yeah for sure it's a new chapter and I
like this how the things going and why
not combine both of them right alireza
thank you very much for joining us uh
I'll see you around thank you guys back
to you thank you Christian